hello lydia
hi steve good to see you nice to see you
again
you know i have the fondest memories of
uh bratislava
of that
polyglot gallery that was a magic place
it really was and you did a great job
there oh thank you i'm so glad you're
saying that i also have very good
memories of of those times when all the
polyglots and language lovers gathered
here in bratislava yeah
it was lovely it was lovely
now perhaps for my viewers you can
explain
what you do so it's uh
language coaching i see that in your
name in slovakia in your uh
is that on your email or something so
what exactly can you explain what that
is so what i what i do i don't call it
language coaching i call it language
mentoring mentoring sorry mentoring it
was yes sorry yeah so uh so basically
what i do is i help people learn
languages
which i don't even speak this is this is
i guess the biggest difference um
because i believe in order to learn a
language you need to know how to
approach it and it doesn't really matter
which language it is so much
and and you need a lot of motivation and
some systems some some habits to do it
so i basically help people with that i
give them i give them the know-how on
how to learn a language either from
scratch or when they're on an
intermediate level and then i actually
help them achieve it and and uh to to do
it long enough to actually see results
now do you do this face-to-face do you
do it uh via the internet how do you do
it
no no we it's all it's all online
and uh we are basically helping clients
from all over the world and also in
slovakia czech republic and slovakia so
we have two two parts of the company
right and i don't i don't do it in
person i have a team of ten people who
are helping from these courses now
and how long have you been doing this
uh we've been doing it for four years
now yeah we celebrated our fourth
birthday and so do you then deal with uh
individual learners or do you provide
help to the the say the human resources
department of a company or how does it
work
yeah so we we only serve individual
clients right now
so whenever someone uh wants to learn a
language they don't really know how to
do it maybe they tried it in many
different ways but they don't feel like
they have a system in place and they
don't enjoy uh language learning they
don't see the results most of them
then they watch my know-how which i put
into a video course and they can follow
the simple procedure which i describe in
my video course where i explain how to
do everything how to set up a system and
then for some people we have some
courses for 50 people
where
everybody follows their own learning
plan
but we are together in a group an online
group and we help each other on this way
we provide the
incentive to to do individual steps and
everybody follows that at their own pace
in their own time
so what percentage of your market is in
slovakia czech republic and elsewhere
uh right now it's it's a bigger chunk of
the market because uh all my team are
basically czechs and slovaks so we also
focus uh focus on this market much more
right
so it's about
i would say one third maybe right now is
the international market and two thirds
and i presume so and uh of course
slovakia czech republic right there in
the middle of europe so
in addition to english i guess german
french i mean all languages russian are
important to
where you're located in the in the
middle east exactly you actually named
almost all of them the most popular ones
we also have spanish and uh italian
on the list of most popular languages
but everybody's very motivated to learn
languages here for sure right
yeah i mean that's the difference
between
say
slovakia
and say north america where you you have
to look very hard to find people
speaking another language i mean quebec
they speak french lots of spanish
speakers in the us but it's
predominantly english and and
japan is the same way i mean all these
countries where you have a lot of
speakers of their own language maybe
they're less motivated
um
[Music]
what what sort of age group do you deal
with
uh
all age groups basically we in slovakia
that this is interesting we have most
people uh who are interested in our
courses are
basically in my age let's say people
between their after their university
studies or you know after leaving school
um maybe between 25 and 40 let's say and
a big group is actually moms who are on
maternity leave with their with their
children because they cannot attend any
courses and they feel really motivated
to work on their language skills because
they know they will be looking for a job
so is it is this learning then more
related to job opportunities improving
one's uh you know credentials or is it
so it's not so much a cultural thing
[Music]
uh here in slovakia it's more related to
your goals and your opportunities in
life because people realize that if they
don't speak any foreign language they
cannot do much really i mean there's
five five million slovaks in the world
if you don't speak any other language
you you go south north east west and no
one no one understands you right right
so um definitely this it's it's the it's
the will it's the interest in
communicating with other people but also
increasing your job opportunities
all right
and are these people typically
and this gets into a subject i like to
bring up is uh nowadays of course
schools i don't know what's happening in
slovakia but in many places clues are so
schools are closed down
yeah so
um now people are starting to open up
but what i see is they're opening up for
children they're not so much opening up
for older people adults
yes and i mean eventually they will open
up but at the present time they're not
so
do you think that that and of course
we've seen this increase in online
instruction or in your case online
mentoring
perhaps related to online instruction
do you think the world of language
because even though we're both involved
in sort of online language learning
the overwhelming majority of people
learn in traditional schools
yes so do you think there will be a
change when we come out of covet
i think the change is already happening
actually we've seen a huge increase in
uh the demand for our courses
the the moment that the corona lockdown
started in slovakia
uh it was like three times the the
demand that we normally see so people
are definitely uh looking for new
opportunities how to improve their
languages
i think that even when
language schools do open up i think many
people will still worry to go there and
meet in a group of people so they will
still prefer to look for other ways so i
believe that the covid situation will
definitely influence how people look at
language learning and what ways they
follow right
and of course there's been even before
quota there was a big increase in the
number of online tutors it's kind of
been a gradually growing
thing i mean there are a lot of
independent
people there is obviously italki has a
you know a large group of teachers but
also
independent language teachers who set up
and see their business grow have you
seen this have you seen an increase in
the number of uh
online language tutors
yeah i mean uh not not in person i don't
work with these people in any way but uh
yeah i notice it as a user my talking
similar websites which are being created
now
that more people are interested in
teaching online and also more people are
now open to the possibility of having a
conversation online with someone because
i think this also has to do with the
fact that um more and more people let's
say at my age people i'm 31 people my
age are not are not afraid to you know
to call someone uh online because it's
something we do all the time right and
so uh i think that fewer and fewer
people uh worry about these technical uh
issues right and that's why they're open
to call their friends have a language
lesson you know have a consultation with
someone online so i think
with time naturally you know more and
more people who are now getting to uh to
older age i don't know how to put it uh
they will not worry about it because
they have already quite a lot of
experience right whereas 10 years ago um
it would be a normal thing for 20 year
olds but maybe not so normal for older
people
and how do you think
online instruction and of course this
gets to some of your advice to people on
how to learn languages so how
how do you what's the role of the sort
of online or or remote language learning
versus classroom language learning
so
i think the biggest difference is in the
learner's expectations on how the
learning should happen i think that if
people uh go to traditional language
classes they expect the teacher to teach
them and they think that this is what
they pay for right they want an expert
who has the knowledge the
the the information the pieces of the
language
and uh the teacher
gives the knowledge to the students
right whereas i think the biggest
difference and you see it in the
community of polyglots yourself i
believe is that we don't expect anyone
to teach us right we we find we look for
ways how to we can learn the stuff how
we can spend time with the language we
come up with creative ways how to read
something or listen to something and
once we find something that we like we
spend a lot of time with it and ta-da
you know a few months later you speak
the language so i think this is the
point not necessarily that quickly but
okay right
i mean if uh you know if someone applies
themselves i believe every day for like
an hour
they can definitely see a huge
improvement oh absolutely absolutely so
so i think that
this is this is the interesting change
for me in this whole coveted situation
and how more and more people are
starting to look for online resources
and online language learning because i
think they will understand uh better
that they need to actually do the work
you know they will not look for a
teacher or they just come they show up
for the lesson and the teacher does the
job they realize that they actually need
to do the learning and i think this can
improve their results a lot
i mean i certainly find that if i go if
i'm reading something in a language that
i'm learning and i'm curious about the
grammar
then there are lots of resources i can
look it up if i want to look up arab
verbs if i want to look up
her i mean even right now i'm learning
arabic and persian and turkish which are
less you know studied than other
languages and yet there's an abundance
of resources when i was doing romanian i
downloaded this and phenomenal grammar
pdf that's free
and and it's full of examples and
and so when you're curious you know
there's all kinds of resources as you
say the teacher doesn't need to be the
expert who knows the language and is
going to give you this the secret to the
language
however
what i see you know here in canada of
course now the schools are shut down so
teachers are trying to teach online and
the first sort of instinct of the
traditional teacher is to take what they
do in the classroom and simply make it
available online
so they use zoom or they use whatever
they use so that they take the classroom
and put it online
and do you think that will be the model
going forward or do you think they'll
maybe have to change what they do i'm
sure they will and actually today i had
i had a call with a friend who who is an
online tutor and she says that she she
noticed that people are already i mean
people are already changing the way they
teach languages because this
you cannot hold the attention of people
on in an online session in the same way
you do it in a classroom you cannot
interact with them so
in the same way so they are now looking
for ways how to how to get the attention
of their students and i think if someone
um decides to stay exactly with the
traditional way they will soon find out
that they are not competitive because
there will be so many other people
teaching that students will prefer you
know interact other other types of
interaction with the with us with the
teacher oh i don't i don't think this
will just move online okay now the
problem is so if you're in a classroom
you have 25 often children or even i
guess adult language classes tend to be
smaller than that
and people always say to me for example
with links so how would you use link in
the classroom
because with link it's just you listen
and read and and if you do interact with
the tutor it's one on one
but in a classroom the teacher has 20 or
so
and so the problem for the teacher
always becomes what can i do to keep
them busy
what you know and so they create
activities in the classroom
in order to keep people busy
regardless
whether that's the most effective way to
teach or not
yes
so then what's going to happen are our
teachers language teachers going to have
more smaller individual classes but
fewer of them
or or how is this going to develop in
your opinion yeah so i've given this
quite a lot of thought and i can totally
imagine that people uh that for example
link is used in in classroom i can
absolutely imagine that someone you know
the students come and one of them is
reading a book another one i explain a
computer game another one is working
with a with a language app there are so
many ways to learn the language right
and everybody picks something else
i believe that this is in a real
classroom this is what you're saying
could be the situation once we have
bricks and brick and mortar schools
again that the students will be allowed
to do
not quite what they want but a variety
of different activities on their own in
the class
yeah and i'm talking about a
hypothetical classroom obviously maybe
way in the future but this is what i i
can totally imagine working
i can i think that the the goal of the
teacher would not be to make sure that
the you know that whatever the students
do in the class that that's the learning
that happens or the majority of the
learning but they would make sure that
um
they would use some part of the lesson
to talk to the to the students about
what they have just read or what they
have that they've just done right maybe
maybe you know students could do all of
these activities at home and then they
would come to the lesson only to discuss
something so it would be basically just
conversation lessons and grammar
clarification let's say right i believe
this is this is the bigger the biggest
input where a teacher can help their
students right
i agree with you 100 and and if the
student is curious about some point of
grammar and asks the teacher why this
and the teacher explains it that has a
greater likelihood of actually staying
in in the brain of the of the learner if
on the other hand the teacher says today
we're going to learn the subjunctive
exactly that has very little impact i'm
not ready for the subjunctive i don't
want the subject yeah because the
student's brain is like the subjunctive
what do i need it for right why why
should i care so
maybe maybe the next step would even be
that the student comes and asks um tell
me what is this uh quiero que tengas you
know or something like the form of the
subjunctive let's say and the teacher
says you know what let me find a website
for you where this is explained why
don't you read it and if you have any
questions you know come to me and ask me
and i believe that in this way the
teacher could just be the guide who
basically guides the guides the students
to figure out the answers because as you
said there are resources for any
language out there online so all you
need to do is just be curious and then
look for the answers in the materials
right
and you know you mentioned okay the
subjunctive it could be case endings in
slavic languages or verbs of motion
which i still have trouble with
but the teacher could also encourage
people in the classroom to give examples
because i'm a big believer in examples
rather than explanations and so if you
had the students in the class each one
come up with an example of
the instrumental case in russian or
something like that so
i think that kind of focusing on
examples in the classroom would also be
effective in a classroom but if we get
back to online instruction then so so
what how do you see online instruction
how is it going to be online instruction
typically is one on one or not
necessarily
yeah yeah mostly mostly it happens like
that i know that now teachers are coming
up with new ways because they are forced
especially teachers from public schools
they have to spend time with the with
the children so they usually use zoom
calls or something
i i don't know how these how these
lessons go or how you know what it looks
like so i i cannot say what it will be
like but i i truly believe that the
corona situation what it can change is
that it will help people realize that
most of the learning should should
happen outside of the class so now
teachers are basically forced to give
students more homework because they
cannot spend as much time with them in
the lesson right and and i think once
that students realize well i can
actually read these texts by myself i
can look up the words which are new we
don't have to do it all together 20
students maybe it will take me less time
than it would take us in the classroom
and i can spend more time doing
something else
i think that this might be quite
eye-opening for many students as well as
teachers
because i really believe that the time
spent with the teacher should not be the
only time that a person left well of
course of course and the teacher
shouldn't decide what the learner is
going to read or listen to exactly
exactly yeah so
ideally what it could bring is the
teacher says okay guys so your homework
is to read you know either the text in
the textbook or a similar text of your
choice right but then of course we get
to the problem of testing i mean the
teachers need to give grades and i think
this is this is a sore point right well
i think i think and and even before that
i think
the teacher could say here is a range of
material that you can choose from yeah
it wouldn't be open-ended you know so
that there might be some restriction on
what they can use
uh but yeah testing is a big issue and
i always raise the
the of course the situation say in
canada or north america very different
from slovakia i think people are more
motivated to learn languages in europe
generally than here
however you have the situation that
when i went to school we had french
every day we had it sent you know from
grade two and no one could speak the
language
yeah and yet
we had tests we had tests i had tests
all the time i did well in the tests and
by the age of 16 i couldn't speak french
and so students can do quite well in
tests
and still and not be able to speak and
not understand very well
and and the main reason is because they
haven't
read or listened very much in other
words they haven't consumed very much of
the language
yes and yeah
so the question is you know we can test
like i i have a tremendous aversion to
listening comprehension questions
i believe that whatever i understand
that's my business
if i can i understand it wrong that's my
business i understood only 50 that's my
business the most important thing is
that i read it and i listened to it so
that all of that language was kind of
entering my brain
don't bother me with these comprehension
questions yeah uh i i i just have a
tremendous aversion to all form of
testing i i believe that if we could so
i mean at link we measure activity
essentially how many words have you read
how many words have you looked up how
many hours have you listened and the
assumption is that if you maintain a
certain level of activity
you will improve
yes that's exactly my system and and if
you have if you are put in a situation
where you need the language or you have
an opportunity to use the language
you'll improve very quickly as long as
you have put all of that you know active
effort into listening and reading and
speaking and writing so that that could
but is it possible that schools could
persuade the parents and the school
administrators that all we need to
measure
is how active
these students are with the language and
not necessarily whether they get the
subjunctive right
because you know very well that you can
get the subjunctive or any grammar issue
you can get it right one day and get it
wrong the next day exactly can i
actually yes i actually think that the
the reason why this happens is because
of testing because if you want to test
someone what what happens is the teacher
says okay kids tomorrow we have a test
in the subjunctive right so the kids
learn a few i don't know
definitions or something and and they
all cram it into their short-term memory
right
but because they know they will be
tested on it and they need to know these
words on on a certain date right whereas
i think what actually happens is uh
whether with vocabulary or grammar what
you do is you assimilate stuff step by
step and uh let's say i heard a word uh
three times
you know the question is do i know it or
do i not know it in a test
someone wants to tell me exactly you
know this word or you don't know this
word but maybe i know it passively now
and if i hear it two or three more times
and then i use it once in a conversation
i will know it perfectly well so
this is what i see as the biggest
problem with testing that it tries to
catch a certain level of your knowledge
on a certain point whereas it's a
it's a process of development right
exactly and how you do on the test now
is not necessarily a good predictor
of how well you will learn the language
and if that test discourages you
in fact it might have a very negative
effect on your
possibility of eventually learning that
language and let alone i mean the stress
of being tested i mean when whenever
anyone wants to test me like okay lydia
so you speak these languages you know
let me test you in french or whatever i
get so stressed out that i feel like a
total beginner you know but if i meet
someone if i'm on holiday and i meet
someone and they're nice and they're not
testing my french we're just speaking i
feel comfortable and i can use it
fluently so i believe that if people
base their self-assessment only on the
results of a test where they were under
stress i believe they don't really have
a clear picture of their level
and and i think the tests are
um you know there was the example for
example in in the canadian government
you get a bonus for being bilingual
in order to get that boldness you have
to pass the test
and so if on your french you get the
subjunctive subjunctive wrong they may
not
give you your bonus and yet it's very
possible that someone who can get the
subjunctive wrong can sit in a meeting
that say in french and not understand
what's going on and not be able to
communicate whereas someone else who
gets the subjunctive wrong is fully able
to participate in the meeting
understands what's going on and is able
to explain whatever he or she has to say
so it's a very arbitrary and of course
that's the only way it could be because
the test has to find something to mark
you down on right yeah
yeah and this is exactly the problem so
when when you have a school that wants
to or a language school that wants to
give a certificate like you have passed
this then you are on this level what can
they test other than the material that
they have covered right so i believe
this is the problem
this is why they are still using
textbooks because they want to have a
set of words which have been
learned or you know taught in the
lessons and and they test you on those
words and then everybody gets an a and
people feel they don't really speak the
language because they don't because they
haven't really put into work right
you know i have the feeling that we
could go on for a long time discussing
this
i think it's great what you're doing um
i don't know when we'll uh have another
polyglot meeting we gotta wait to sort
of get to the other side of this coded
thing
but uh
thank you for uh coming to visit
uh sounds very interesting we'll leave a
link to your uh site in the description
box thank you and i look forward to the
next time when we can meet face to face
i hope it's soon
okay see you then yeah bye-bye